Anna Garcia a seamstress and rural
Bolivia is aiming to make it big with
traditional Bolivian folk music ever
since Evo Morales became the country's
first indigenous president traditional
music has been growing in popularity
will Anna Garcia finally be able to earn
a living with her music it's market day
and by el mozo a suburb of Cochabamba
short
Anna Garcia is a genuine cholita as they
are called here an indigenous woman from
the Bolivian countryside here at the
market she sells skirts and blouses that
she sews herself are already sold
I make them to measure the poeta is a
skirt worn by rural women for Anna
Garcia it's part of the Bolivian
identity more than 30 euros apiece
the garments are not cheap Anna Garcia
has worn a poeta since she was a child
okay Callie and I always work on Yoona
they're so warm I feel naked when I
don't have one on oh yeah makes me
strong I can lift heavier weights
because it fits snugly around my hips no
matter what the load we can carry it it
makes me so strong I could beat him up I
stop a little bigger the skirt is tied
so tightly that it really does help you
carry heavy loads Anna's husband France
is familiar with his wife's love of the
skirts he's been married to her for 35
years
next day they head out to shoot Ana
Garcia's new DVD she's hoping to reach a
larger audience with folk dances like
the quake this is how the cueca goes we
asked a partner to dance first we tapped
like this that's how we did Olivia she's
pinning her hopes of a breakthrough on
this music video the Garcias planned to
post it on YouTube and Facebook and a
son Franklin is directing just a little
bit forward right two steps a little
closer Annabelle's wearing her high
heels mama I love this way the rest of
the family have joined in to support her
the daughter's dance
and husband Frances on the guitar mows
the scattered trying to preserve the
culture of the cholita with our videos
my mother Anna wants this musical
tradition later in the day in the center
of Cochabamba it's time to advance her
career Anna Garcia wants to do more than
perform at parties she wants to be on TV
which is why she has approached Don
Laurel a well-known music producer
he created the showed that cosmos a TV
talent show for traditional indigenous
Bolivian music it's very original and
down-to-earth she breathes new life into
these traditional songs with lots of
energy and enthusiasm but for now Anna
will have to wait Don Lauro can't
promise her an appearance on its show
just yet
a day later she's on her way to a sound
studio to work on her new album she
always has her songbook with her all the
lyrics are in Quechua the most spoken
indigenous language in Bolivia caparison
you're Santa
yeah I'm singing about st. James this is
a folk song in Quechua I write my songs
myself it's about believing
about friendship and love the market for
this kind of music has developed in
Bolivia in recent years and ana Garcia
recognized an opportunity for herself
Ana Garcia's music is rooted in the
Bolivian countryside she grew up here in
Pokhara grande an hour's drive from
Cochabamba there used to be nothing here
but fields this is where she lived as a
child she hasn't been here for 35 years
she's looking for the family home she
still remembers one of the neighbors yes
over there the empty old mud-walled
building was home to Ana and her family
this village is where she first
performed and dreamed of a career as a
musician
her parents were farmers
miss Pappas miss Pappas day me my father
was a drunk my parents used to go out
and leave me alone with the animals and
my brothers and sisters I really
suffered here that's something I've
never forgot the worst moment was when
her mother forbade her to play music
then at the age of 25 France who became
her husband rescued her from her
miserable situation she broke off all
contact to her parents darling
story being Gus I'm doing well thanks to
my talent when I sing and dance I leave
everything behind me
today they have something to celebrate
Anna Garcia is finally going to be on
television
Don Lauro has invited her to appear in
his show the entire family is here all
the erasers in anytime
none of Anna's children dressed in
traditional bolivian garb on a daily
basis even though she tried her best to
convince them to do so I always wanted
to dress my daughters in the foyer but I
think they were a little bit embarrassed
in front of their friends very practical
boy Jana is very heavy
you can't move very freely in it now the
big day has arrived there showed the
cosmos with Don Lauro
Anna Garcia is excited soon everyone
across Bolivia will see her
everyone is watching today the audience
here and the people in front of their TV
screens at home Anna Garcia she's here
today with some wonderful musicians
they'll perform the song sucker Bellator
panel will sing four songs and hopefully
win over the audience
her son Franklin is recording the big
moment and by the third song the ice has
been broken
Oh
it was great a big success I'm very
happy I love to dance and sing the TV
appearance was a huge step forward in
her music career now Anna Garcia is
hoping to perform at concerts and other
events until one day she gets her big
break